welcome back to CBS this morning hope
you made it home safely for a lot of
people that is still not the case and
they are not happy we begin with that a
nasty winter storm is making it
difficult for people returning to work
in school in the Midwest after this
Thanksgiving holiday millions of people
are under storm warnings and watches
there they're seeing heavy snow and
winds up to 50 miles an hour some parts
of Illinois broke an all-time snowfall
record for November and some areas could
see more than a foot of snow today more
than 1,200 flights had to be canceled
yesterday and more than 5,000 others
were delayed on one of the busiest
travel days of the year
Dean Reynolds is out in the snow near
Chicago but we first want to go to Kris
Van Cleave at Washington's Reagan
National Airport Chris good morning
well good morning this gives you a sense
what it's like getting out of Chicago
this morning this flight delayed 12
hours the rest canceled canceled
canceled you're going to see more delays
and cancellations throughout the day
already this morning we know that more
than 500 flights have been canceled
hundreds more delayed and remember it is
early yesterday almost half of all
flights at Kansas City's Airport were
grounded in Chicago more than 800 at
O'Hare and over 120 more Chicago Midway
were canceled due to the storm airlines
wave change fees for flights in the
Midwest and four days encouraged
travelers to change their route the
roads weren't much better remember
Sunday was going to be the busiest day
on the roads as more than 49 million
Americans were expected to travel for
Thanksgiving yesterday was the drive
home nearly 200 car accidents were
reported Sunday across Iowa Missouri and
Nebraska as the snow and wind created
blizzard conditions at times they're
away from the bad weather this was
described as a traffic nightmare the
Delaware Memorial Bridge was closed in
both directions for six hours Sunday
night after a gas leak was discovered on
a typical day 80,000 cars used that
bridge which links Interstate 95 to the
Jersey Turnpike and other key roads in
the Northeast and this well this is Los
Angeles delays on all the roads entering
the departure level at LAX brought
traffic to a standstill for hours if you
were riding Amtrak last night some
passengers saw delays up to five hours
there and here at Reagan National
Airport traffic was so bad some people
were bailing out of their cars and
running to the terminal Nora
oh my goodness Chris I had a safe flight
back that was a little bit easier on the
Northeast so thank you Chris